[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt samira und ich wir sitzen gerade
eben welchem zimmer in das kinderzimmer
und zwar wisse ja steht bei mir die
geburt kurz bevor
und ich habe mein letztes rezept video
letzte woche gedreht und seit etwa einer
woche ist es mir ziemlich langweilig
deswegen habe ich mir überlegt com nutzt
doch einfach mal die zeit noch vor der
geburt und streich einfach sagen wir als
zimmer und das habe ich jetzt gemacht
und es hat mir das zimmer war am anfang
ganz weiß und ganz leer und wir wohnen
jetzt schon seit über eineinhalb jahren
hier und wir sind einfach nie dazu
gekommen
also es war schon immer auf dem plan das
wird diesmal streichen wir hatten ja
auch mal so einen schönen teppich geholt
und nichts an ihrer marke und sowieso
ganz gerne und hat sich das dann eben
gewünscht und hat sich zum beispiel das
motiv daneben ausgesucht und ich will
jetzt einfach mal sagen ich zeige euch
mal ganz kurz wie das zimmer vorher
aussah das war nämlich ziemlich weiß und
dann würde ich sagen legen wir direkt
los und ich zeige euch einfach wie wir
das gemacht haben also jetzt immer hier
in samira kinderzimmer und es sieht
jetzt natürlich ziemlich unspektakulär
auf und ich stehe vor einer weißen wand
hier steht ihr bett das muss ich gleich
noch weg räumen und ich habe jetzt
bereits schon mal das was ich an
zeichnen möchte das mit bleistift
bisschen vorgezeichnet und zwar ist die
samira so neuen fan und wir haben ja
auch einen teppich mal gekauft und den
haben jetzt gerade raus weil damit er
nicht dreckig wird auf jeden fall heute
überlegt aus ihrem bauch einmal mit zwei
eulen auch nach schaukel die habe ich
internet vorgezeichnet das mache ich
gleich noch
und ja damit einfach das zimmer so ein
bisschen bunt aber es darf alle zu bunt
werden weil ich finde wenn so ein
kinderzimmer zu bunt wird dann ist auch
ein bisserl zu viel fürs kind also es
wird schon noch angenehm sein
und ich sage ich jetzt einfach mal wie
ich loslege und zwar muss ich jetzt erst
mal den boden noch bisschen abdecken das
nicht dreckig wird murat schiebt mir
noch das bett weg da unten kommt
übrigens so ein grüner streifen sondern
zu einer grundfarbe hin
aber so der hintergrund da bleibt dann
schon weiß weil ja wie gesagt zu bunt
holz sind ordnet und da müssen wir noch
die leisten abgeben und
die steckdose das machen wir jetzt ganz
kurz und dann gibts auch direkt los und
ich zeige mich dann was ich einfach für
materialien belegte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt unten die leisten und die
steckdose abgeklebt und jetzt fange ich
direkt an und zwar will ich euch diesen
grünen streifen und damit eben auch
schön gerade wird muss ich das jetzt
auch mit klebeband ebenso abkleben
und ich mache jetzt einfach die linie
als ich möchte den streifen 50
zentimeter hoch ab der leiste rechne ich
das jetzt mesz ab und zieh mir dann mit
einer wasserwaage eben den streifen
damit sind auch schon gerade ist und
damit abgelegt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so jetzt habe ich den streifen abgeklebt
und dann müsste auch immer gut mit dem
finger fest drücken damit dass später
die farbe nicht hoch läuft und an der
stelle kann ich auch schon was sagen
also ich nehme da immer gutes klebeband
das ist jetzt eins von tesa gewesen es
gibt natürlich auch andere gute
klebebänder auf jeden fall solle direkt
darauf achten dass wir da jetzt spart
unseren billiges 1 euro ding zum
beispiel nimmt weil das bereut ihr
später denn diese günstigen klebebänder
diese kräftig kleben hat einfach gut an
der wand und an den leisten und dann ist
einfach so wer billig kauft kauft
zweimal das ist wie in der küche also da
würde ich auf jeden fall wert darauf
legen dass ihr dann gutes habt und
übrigens habe ich mir alle sachen
entweder im baumarkt geholt oder in
mannheim da geht es um richtig kohle
bastelladen da bin ich total gerne wo
rat vertreten schon die augen oder
weniger gern bei die idee und holte hat
eigentlich immer was also macht findet
da halt immer was also auch heuer nichts
braucht findet man immer was würde ich
auch nicht nichts was braucht pro jahr
das ist nicht so
so und jetzt muss ich damit die farbe
ich mich städten unteren teil jetzt hier
grün und damit die farbe jetzt später
schön eben gerade wird und nicht
irgendwie in die regeln rein läuft weil
die wand ist ja nicht ganz glatt sondern
hat so dieses tapetenmuster muss ich
jetzt diesen abschluss hier abdichten
und das mache ich jetzt einfach mit
bisschen weiß das ist ein richtig toller
trick war immer einer der wenn nicht
möglich die säle gezeigt und das ist ein
toller trick wenn man auch zum beispiel
diese streifen an der wand machen möchte
wenn wieder einmal das habe ich das auch
in unserer ersten wohnung gemacht haben
was auch längsstreifen und wenn man das
eben schon abdichtet dann hat man
wirklich eine ganz gerade und dann läuft
es eben nicht runter jetzt mit der
kamera gleich ein bisschen mehr drauf ja
wenn du das machst du da nehme ich
einfach die ganz normale wandfarbe also
die unter grundfarbe ob jetzt irgendwie
ein beigefarbenes zimmer
abrissunternehmen nicht weiß eben die
farbe die ihr hier als hintergrund habe
das ist ganz wichtig also nicht das ist
damit weiß abdichtet oder romand war ich
blau oder
und jetzt muss man sich das vorstellen
wie nur wieso eine versiegelung hat sich
streicht dann auch von unten nach oben
und dann ist einfach dieser übergang von
klebeband und wand schön dicht und da
kann dann später eben die grüne farbe
nicht darunter
und das mache ich jetzt einfach komplett
in streifen entlang man indes auch diese
tropf nasentropfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt muss das weiß natürlich erstmal
trocknen damit ich später dann den
grünen streifen kann aber um die
wartezeit zu überbrücken fange ich schon
mal mit dem baumann
denn das sicher weiter oben und dafür
nehme ich jetzt auch wandfarben und es
ist auch ganz wichtig dass ihr
wandfarben nehmt und keine acrylfarben
oder öl farben zb denn die wandbemalung
wieder nicht für immer da dran bleiben
also schätze ich mal
wir ziehen ja auch irgendwann wieder
raus und da muss man das eben auch
wieder über malen können und deswegen
den schwanz haben die sind ja auf
wasserbasis
da kann dann auch nichts passieren
deswegen habe ich jetzt zum beispiel
auch sein altes t-shirt für murat an so
ein altes polo und wenn da irgendwas
dann kommt dann kann ich später einfach
in die waschmaschine schmeißen so lange
es noch feucht ist dann ist es eben auch
gleich wieder weg dessen könne allen
polos ist mein polo was ich immer an
süße liegt passaus geht ja wieder raus
das ist vom photo of the loom
das flugzeug ist bewusst dafür muss ich
zwei stunden schwarz arbeiten mensch
morath und jetzt habe ich hier so ein
dunkles braun hob saarland was ich kann
auf krieg katholisches aufmacht mein
gott ich hab's selbst tv und das könnte
ich mir jetzt einfach in so einem
kleinen teller ein und kann damit jetzt
schon x mal und dafür habe ich jetzt so
ein paar feine tapete also aufwand
pinsel dann habe ich hier noch ganz
normale borsten pinsel und mit denen man
sich jetzt den baum an und kann dann
eben auch feinere sachen arbeiten
[Musik]
duscha tieren oder bleibt ist muss man
extra tiere mit schwarzer aber ich habe
gerade kein schwarz da muss man auch
kaufen
ja ich meine ich ganz kaufen bereich ich
gehe es nach erholen aber weil das ich
gerade so aus dass sich aus jetzt ist
sicherlich auch nicht malen können will
naja als kannst du mal da kannst du ja
immer strichmännchen male und soja
fangen wir an mich zu hacken ja aber ich
schaue jetzt noch mal stand zufrieden er
hat so sieht's aus echt cool aus
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt so weit hoch mal ist auch
noch mit doch schon danach gewählt danke
du machst grün ist am boden muss ich mal
also in westafrika ist das ist so wie im
wahren leben geführt durch die bäume und
ich tue das auch sagen was auf dem boden
liegt genau
[Musik]
den bau habe ich jetzt fertiggemacht und
und trocknen lassen
also eigentlich sagte gestern nach dem
streichen damit den hunger habe alles
gegessen und danach hatte ich keine lust
mehr
aber es wird auch nicht schlecht ernährt
sich auch hier dieser weiße streifen
getrocknet und jetzt werde ich mit so
einem kleinen roller und der grünen
farbe die ich hab das ja eine wandfarbe
werde ich jetzt unten den grünen
streifen einfach durch streichen und
dann nehme ich mir jetzt noch so ein
gitter damit ich das eben immer schön
abstreifen kann
und das setzt sich jetzt einfach direkt
hier rein kann dann die farbe aufnehmen
und insel abstreifen und dann beginne
ich jetzt einfach auf der einen seite
und arbeite mich eben nach links durch
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier unten den baumstamm
fertig machen und da bin nämlich wieder
das braun und nehmen dann auch gleich
noch ein bisschen schwarz und so ein
bisschen schattierungen eben in dem baum
reinzubekommen
[Musik]
jetzt ist das grün gestrichen und jetzt
kann ich auch schon das kreppband
abziehen
das heißt während die farbe noch feucht
ist und das mache ich jetzt mal eben
schnell
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt eben noch mit bleistift
vorgezeichnet und mal die jetzt einfach
mit verschiedenen farben bunt an
ich habe jetzt so eine große und eine
kleine eule die familie wollte nämlich
unbedingt sich selber und ihre kleine
schwester als säule und ja diebe mache
ich jetzt einfach ganz schnell
[Musik]
die eulen sind jetzt fertig und jetzt
kann ich den baum noch fertig
ausgestalten und da mal ich jetzt noch
ein paar blätter hin an die wand kommen
dann noch ein paar schmetterlinge und
das mache ich jetzt eben wieder mit den
wandfarben damit ich mir zum dunklen ein
dunkles grün und ein gelb da hab ich so
ein bisschen hellgrün und macht es eben
noch mit biss und das mache ich jetzt
kurz dann sind wir schon verstrahlt
[Musik]
also so miraß zimmer ist jetzt fertig
und wir zeigen euch jetzt einfach die
einzelnen elemente und die wände und was
wir alles verschönert haben und dieses
motiv hat sich übrigens die samira
ausgesucht du wolltest der unbedingt
zwei eulen gilt als die große die kleine
schwester ella und als ich das auch
instagram gepostet hab das war ganz
witzig da haben wir ein paar geschrieben
dass allem zu hause gar nicht gut sind
und die einheit geschrieben jahr wegen
der aberglaube dann habe ich das
recherchiert und ja es steht wirklich
sehr viel im internet aber ich muss euch
sagen ich bin nicht abergläubisch und ja
ich finde man kann überall was rein
interpretieren aber ich glaube von mira
ist ganz glücklich mit ihren eulen und
der murat freut sich denn murat für was
stehen eulen für reichtum genau und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach hier noch
schnell den rest
[Musik]
unter den eulen steht übrigens hier so
miraß bett und zwar ist es so ein ganz
normales erwachsenen bett 2 auf 1 meter
und wir haben uns das eben so ausgesucht
dass sie hier noch schubladen darunter
hat das ist immer ganz praktisch weil
man da einfach direkt bettwäsche und zum
beispiel kuscheltiere verstauen kann und
über ihrem bett da hängt dieses
moskitonetz ich finde ich mache immer so
wie sie ihren prinzessinnen mäßig und so
ein bisschen wohnlich und es gefällt ihr
auch ganz gut
und hier haben wir direkt dann die
zweite band die ich gemalt habe und zwar
mit den schmetterlingen und nebendran da
haben wir diese wunderschöne lampe und
zwar haben wir das zwei mädels geschickt
von love made me die machen die lampen
nämlich selber durch alles handarbeit
und ich finde es echt super wie toll die
das gebastelt haben
und ja sie ihre fans auch richtig gut
vor allen dingen konnten wir einfach ein
wunschmotiv und einem wunsch farbe
aussuchen und haben das dann eben
bekommen
wieso leds sie brauchen noch wenige
strom genau spart man das ist schon
beachtlich und man muss halt auch nichts
anbauen wir haben einfach zwei nägel
hierdurch geschlagen und es ist ja so
leicht diese lampe also die kann man
überall anbringen und hier hinten dran
hat sie dann eben diesen an aus knopf
und entweder kann das verstecken oder so
wie ich einfach sachen davor stellte
inter versteckt und der bilderrahmen den
haben wir übrigens zusammen ihrer geburt
bekommen vorüber ja fast fünf jahren und
zwar hat es eine freundin damals gemacht
das wird alles per hand bestickt also es
ist ein kreuz stich und da wurde
wirklich jedes einzelne detail und
vietnam hagel tage dafür gebraucht bis
das stimmt und jetzt am iran so eine
kommode bekommen von uns und zwar für
die kleidung weil ich es einfach
praktischer finde klamotten in den
schubladen aufzubewahren gerade wenn man
es so hoch kann 3 und steckt das sieht
man immer gleich was man hat und kann
einfach alles einfach rausziehen
und dann eben wieder verschließen und ja
finde ich ganz praktisch den hat
übrigens die moral zusammengebaut
deswegen hängt also ein bisschen damit
gehört und hier hat es einfach ihre
sachen die sie dann auf hängt da unten
noch ein paar taschen und so die
oberteile die wir zusammen gelegt haben
und ich denke das ist so ganz
übersichtlich vor allen dingen geräts
und hatten die durcheinander und macht
halt immer unübersichtlichen
kleiderschrank
[Musik]
und auf der seite also hier ist die tür
zusammen das kinderzimmer und da habe
ich ihr oben ebenso einen bügel gehen
gemacht hätten dass kleider stunde gerne
zum türflügel und da hat seit ihre
taschen die tasche zum beispiel haben
wir auch geschenkt gekriegt und zwar von
gunther nadel und total süß also ich
glaube auch sie hatten
der wander shop den könnt ihr euch gerne
mal verlinken und es hat sich selber
genäht und da eben noch samira darauf
gedruckt richtig schön und hier neben
dran haben wir dann auch so eine kommode
da hat sie dann ihre spielsachen drin
und beim parsen in schubladen dran oder
türen und das sind die bücher treten die
gesellschaftsspiele und so weiter und da
haben wir auch eine hübsche lampe die
habe ich auch zugeschickt bekommen von
der zuschauerin und zwar von monats
bastelstube der zu selber gemacht und
hat daneben gefragt was samira gern mag
und ich habe angst prinzessinnen und
eulen und es hat eben richtig schön
verbunden
dann haben wir dann eben dran eben auch
mal noch mal so eine kleine kommode mit
eben diesen kisten und körben und da hat
sie dann eben alles sortiert und kann da
immer alles schön wieder aufräumen und
jetzt mal samira hier auch gerade an
ihrem schreibtisch
[Musik]
du kannst ja toll malen und sandra sag
mal wie oft mich in dein zimmer
aufräumen
[Musik]
die jeden tag geld genau und da drüben
habe ich jetzt auch einmal diese
schmetterlinge dran gemalt noch ein paar
blumen das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen
gemütlicher aus und da unten haben wir
jetzt dann eigentlich nur noch samira
skill level domain natur zeigen wieder
geht das ist so cool und da genau
richtig kohle nehme ich doch immer mit
ins wohnzimmer gelb wenn man fernseh
gucken oder irgendwas machen und einfach
zusammen herum liegen so und hier steht
so murat ein berühmter putzeimer diät
ist aber weg räumen können
er steht da bin dir die fruchtblase
platzt das ist alles sauber machen kann
und der teppich hier das war übrigens
oder auslöser zusammen
wie sagt man da sie keine ahnung auf
jeden fall mag die rollen so gerne weil
sie diesen teppich hat den haben wir
immer geholt aber ich kann nicht so ganz
empfehlen weil ein weißer teppich in
einem kinderzimmer da wird halt immer
schmutzig und den muss man eigentlich
regelmäßig putzen und er hat trotzdem
immer wieder diesen grauschleier aber
jetzt gucken wir mal ich denke da hält
noch eine zeit lang durch
und ja typisch aus das zimmer einmal
komplett gesehen gefällt dir dein zimmer
jetzt bestraft finde ich hab mit genuss
bei joghurt beschäftigt
und ja also ich habe er geplant dass ich
in zukunft auch öfter mal solche videos
mache ich wurde da auch auf instagram
schon angeschrieben
ich hatte ja mal irgendwann angekündigt
dass ich mal do it yourself videos mache
ich habe auch unsere wohnzimmer möglich
selber gebaut und wollte es auch mal
verfilmen aber ich kam eigentlich gesagt
nie dazu aber ich denke dass wir nichts
ist ja einfach damit starten und ich
dann zb zwei videos im monat eben auch
überaus yourself ideen machen
und ja ich wurde auch gefragt woher das
überhaupt kommt also ich hab halt in
meiner jugendzeit auch immer ganz gerne
kinderzimmer verschönert und hab mir da
immer motive ausgesucht oder die eltern
haben sich motive ausgesucht und da habe
ich das eben gemacht in der schule habe
ich das auch regelmäßig gemacht wo auch
immer ganz schön mit den grundschülern
dazusitzen und zu malen zu basteln und
ich denke wenn euch das interessiert
würde ich das auf jeden fall als video
reihe machen mit der samira zusammen
zaubertrick den sagst du mir gleich wenn
man fertig sind okay ja und auf jeden
fall hoffe ich dass euch das video
gefallen hat und die idee neues gefallen
haben
vielleicht möchte jemand nachmachen und
hat jetzt einfach inspirationen gefunden
für sein eigenes kinderzimmer oder fürs
kinderzimmer vom eigenen kind und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen vielleicht und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder biss dann teams
nicht erwarten bis sie kommt gerne
schlussendlich
[Musik]